bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 19 avril par dizaines de milliers
les albanais du kosovo continuent de
fuir menaces et du nettoyage par le vide
père et par les serbes
l'afflux des réfugiés menace la
stabilité des pays voisins dont la
macédoine retour à berlin pour les
députés allemands qui siégeront
désormais dans un nouveau riche stade
transparent nicolas sarkozy président
intérimaire du rpr sollicité par l'udf
où la liste européenne ne pense pas
insurmontable une union avec françois
bay en l'air que l'on respire l'air qui
peut tuer une étude sur la pollution des
villes des montres l'accroissement de la
mortalité des habitants des
agglomérations urbaines
bien sûr après 26 jours de conflit
engagé par les forces de l'otan il est
possible de se contenter d'énumérer des
chiffres à propos des réfugiés albanais
parvenu au monténégro en macédoine et en
albanie
ce matin le haut commissariat aux
réfugiés de naître une nouvelle
estimation plus de 600000 personnes mais
la statistique m vente et les colonnes
de familles fuyant l'armée serbe se soit
encore à partir de christina continuent
d'arriver aux frontières des villages
sont vidés et l'exode semble
interminable
au point que les camps sont saturés en
albanie malgré tous les efforts
humanitaires
reportage à coup cage de nos envoyés
spéciaux anne consigny et fier du jasmin
ce vieil homme soutenu par un policer
servent jusqu'aux limites du territoire
yougoslave est un des derniers à avoir
franchi la frontière hier
il est épuisé il n'arrive plus à marcher
son passage donne lieu à un étonnant
face à face entre des policiers de deux
pays qui à ce moment précis sont en
train de rompre leurs relations
diplomatiques
les albanais n'ose pas avancer et c'est
finalement une équipe de médecins du
monde qui est autorisé à évacuer le
vieux kosovars après lui presque
personne n'est passé par le poste
frontière de maureen ans
cette interruption plutôt inquiétante
permet néanmoins de soulager la ville de
kout caisse beaucoup de réfugiés arrivés
ce week-end son parti ce matin pour
tirana en bus ou en camion mais il reste
de nombreuses irréductibles qui ne
veulent pas quitter les lieux pour
tenter incommode nous ici on est tout un
village on veut rester ensemble et puis
qui va s'occuper de nos tracteurs on se
l'est fait voler pendant qu'on dort il y
en a ceux ci ont été volés récemment un
des pneus et pièces la fluctuation
importante et totalement imprévisible
des réfugiés conflit toute organisation
afin de monter cette école de toile a dû
se transformer temporairement au centre
d'hébergement face à l'afflux le
week-end la ville de fouquet se prépare
elle-même à scolariser des centaines
d'enfants kosovar dans ses propres
établissements
elle a fait appel aux réfugiés
enseignants pour assurer les cours
il a eu plus de 200 réponses l'école s'y
fera en alternance les albanais
continueront à venir à l'école le matin
et l'après midi ce seront les enfants
kosovars qui viendrait se font l'écho
pour soutenir les efforts des albanais
et des nombreuses organisations en
particulier italienne qui sont présentes
à kukes les premiers hélicoptères de
l'otan sont arrivées ici aujourd'hui
ils transportent des purificateurs d'eau
et des rations alimentaires car les
files d'attentes pour les distributions
sont toujours longues à coup caisse
en direct de couquèques monsieur jacques
franquin qui est le porte parole de la
chaire le haut commissaire aux réfugiés
monsieur franck un bon soir quel est
l'état des lieux ce soir on dit que les
frontières sont fermées que des colonnes
de réfugiés attendent encore est ce que
vous attendez un nouveau flux nouvel
exode côté nous sommes très inquiète par
le fait que nous avons reçu beaucoup de
réfugiés dimanche
et depuis lors depuis hier à 3 heures de
l'après midi plus aucun réfugié est
apparu à la frontière est vraiment ne
savons pas du tout ce qu'ils sont
devenus on nous parlait de l'afflux de
35 mille cinquante mille cent mille
réfugiés sur la route et tous ces
personnes ont disparu d'un seul coup
alors vraiment il ya de quoi être très
inquiète évidemment vous n'avez aucune
information donnée par des autorités
officielles des militaires n'ont aucune
information
ce que nous avons ce qui a une voiture
qui a passé aujourd'hui vers 3 heures de
l'après midi qui arrivait à coup kech
arrivant du kosovo ces gens disent non
rien ne rien avoir vu sur la route
ceci dit il n'est de freestyle freestyle
halperin route la route directe qui
arrive à couquèques et nous sommes très
concernés par toute cette masse de
réfugiés qui étaient sur une autre route
qui passait par jack au va et où là nous
n'avons absolument aucune nouvelle donc
vraiment un grand point d'interrogation
pour nous evènement un sujet
d'inquiétude évidemment le reportage de
fontenay montraient des camps déjà
saturé en albanie si les dizaines de
milliers de personnes arrivant plus
comment pouvez-vous envisager de les
accueillir mais notre notre formule que
nous avons toujours développé ici a
toujours été de dire que cook est ce
n'était pas possible pour les réfugiés
il est pas question de les garder ici
d'avoir pour un problème de sécurité
ok c'est quasiment une zone de guerre
puisque il ya eu plusieurs endroits
plusieurs villages ici des environs qui
ont été bombardées par l'artillerie
serbe et il est clair que là où il ya
des positions de l'ue ces cas il c'est
trop dangereux décès des réfugiés donc
nous n'avons ainsi de dégager les gens
vers l'inter de l'albanie ce les 350 me
réfugier de nous avons reçu à peu près
250 mines ont déjà quitté kukes et nous
astreignons à porter assistance à grosso
modo une centaine de mille réfugiés
déjà évidemment énorme monsieur franck à
quelle est la bonne solution s'il y en a
une pour les réfugiés restez en albanie
partir être répartis dans d'autres pays
quelle est votre analyse
écoutez l'analyse est très difficile
pour le moment et surtout à kirkouk est
sous vraiment s'astreint à essayer de
porter assistance aux réfugiés mais
c'est vrai qu'on se pose la question
est-ce que l'albanie va pouvoir
supporter une telle charge 300 350 mille
réfugiés déjà et peut-être beaucoup plus
on ne sait pas à quoi on peut s'attendre
mais c'est clair que si ce qui s'avère
si ce qui est dit et s'avère être vraie
qui encore plus de cent mille personnes
qui sont en attente et qui doivent
arriver son albanie ça représentera plus
que 10% de la population d'albanie et
franchement l'albanie reste quand même
un des pays les plus pauvres d'europe
dans ce monde comment ils vont pouvoir
faire face à cette situation il ya eu
des critiques concernant le hcr où
l'organisation humanitaire dans les
premiers temps est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment qu actuellement compte tenu du
rôle des militaires mais peut-être aussi
est-il confusion entre militaires
humanitaires trouvait le sentiment
quelque temps la situation et est bien
tenue bien dominé par les humanitaires
personne ne peut jamais d qui contrôle
une situation avec 350 milles de
réfugiée dans les bras
c'est une situation très très difficile
nous avons des conditions climatiques
qui sont actuellement exécrables
il a été difficile d'amener l'aide
humanitaire ici à couquèques disons que
maintenant de plus en plus on parvient à
avoir des choses un peu sous contrôle
mais il est clair que le moindre
problème s'agrandit et en l afflux et le
nombre de personnes qui a ici en albanie
mais disons que c'est vrai les critiques
ont été là nous essayons de répondre le
mieux que nous pouvons grâce à une bonne
coordination avec les ong et espérer que
la situation va être mis sous contrôle
par le fait que les conditions
climatiques aussi vont s'améliorer mais
c'est vrai que cette situation difficile
il faut pas le cacher
merci monsieur franquin ce sont des
écoles de tirana qui accueille depuis
deux jours des enfants que ce var l'état
albanais fait de son mieux pour partager
le peu de moyens dont il dispose et pour
le secteur scolaire dix mille enfants
sont concernés
reportage au brier de l'air et patrick
loi on les découvre comme on s'y attend
silencieux les visages marqués
douloureux regardons une télévision qui
déversent sans relâche le malheur et la
détresse de leurs compatriotes
la famille d'anna est arrivé il ya
quinze jours d'une petite ville du
sud-ouest du kosovo neuropsychiatre il a
eu la chance est on tenté de dire de
trouver refuge avec sa femme et ses
trois enfants dans la famille d'une
consoeur de tirana aujourd'hui ils se
partagent à 10 les trois chambres de
l'appartement
notre vie est difficile plein de chagrin
notre objectif aujourd'hui c'est de
survivre
heureusement nous avons reçu un accueil
merveilleux ici tandis que les autres
sont entassés dans des camps la plus
jeune ici et tu auras ta elle a 10 ans
particulièrement meurtri par l'exil
la fillette a longtemps cessé de parler
de rire c'est en espérant la paix there
un peu que ses parents lui ont fait
retrouver le chemin de l'école on compte
29 me réfugier tirana dix mille sont des
enfants quatre cents seulement ont pu
trouver une classe avec des moyens que
l'on c'est dérisoire instituteurs et
professeurs commencent à s'adapter
enfants kosovars albanais ont une langue
et un niveau d'étude à peu près
identique mais leur cauchemar ne se
ressemblent pas
quand elle est arrivée il ya trois jours
elle était enfermée elle ne faisait que
pleurer maintenant elle va mieux grâce à
ses camarades albanais dans la cour de
récréation tous les gamins du monde ont
le même goût du chahut et du jeu mais
quand on tente de lui parler
c'est encore le silence que choisir 20
ans seule l'évocation de son pays fera
naître la joie simple d'un sourire
tristan
plus de 350000 que ce bar sont
aujourd'hui réfugiés en albanie et le
flot ne semble pas pour l'instant de
voir se tarir dans les semaines qui
viennent
ce sont donc des dizaines de milliers
d'enfants qu'il faudra scolarisés ici
une action de solidarité supplémentaire
que le gouvernement albanais sait déjà
qu'il n'aura pas les moyens d'assumer
d'autre part l'albanie souhaite qu'un
accord d'association sur prochainement
signé avec l'union européenne
l'allemagne se montre donc très
partageuse mais la macédoine appel à
l'aide sur le plan économique il
convient de rappeler que l'afflux de
deux cent mille réfugiés que ce var
estimations large en macédoine et la
perte du débouché économique serve pour
les macédoniens c'est toutes proportions
gardées comme si la france perdait d'un
coup le marché allemand et accueillait
six millions de personnes démunies sur
son territoire l'économie macédonienne
et donc sinistrés le gouvernement de
skopje demande aux associations
humanitaires de cesser l'importation
d'aliments pour acheter sur place
voici à travers l'exemple de chefs
d'entreprise rencontrés par nos envoyés
spéciaux
hervé brusini philippe lui dit
l'illustration de ce désarroi économique
en macédoine
c'était une usine avec sa relique du
temps de l'ex yougoslavie la casquette
du gardien sous l'oeil de tito en était
fier ici de fabriquer toutes les
ceintures de sécurité pour la voiture
des balkans laza ça va mais aujourd'hui
au grand désespoir de cet homme aux
cheveux blancs le directeur la maison
mère en serbie a été bombardé alors ici
en macédoine la filiale a dû mettre au
chômage près de 100 personnes
à ses côtés l'autre homme occupe une
partie des locaux vasco d'année ce qui a
créé une société de produits
agroalimentaires patrick a comme ici
mais aussi myrtille griottes et même
promis pour la cosmétique comme la
mousse de chêne les voilà le jeune
entrepreneur est lui aussi en difficulté
dans ma vie nous répondons de produits
mon but c'était de on va pas pour faire
des achats aux paysans et de faire une
production l'hiver nous sommes dans
l'unique plein du pays la paix l'agonie
à 15 km de la grèce la macédoine y
rassemble toute sa richesse agricole 70%
de la culture du blé par exemple et
comme vasco la plupart des producteurs
accumulent de considérables surplus et
tout cela parce que la guerre bloquent
les routes dans les légumes frêche
s'étaient rendus nous vendons beaucoup
il vous savez mais aussi en bosnie en
croatie
c'est absolument pas possible de passer
parce que il faut passer la bulgarie la
roumanie la hongrie la croatie pour
venir à bout ce n'est c'était absolument
absolument absolument
là où nous travaillons en bout ce n'est
actuellement il nous faut faire je pense
trois fois plus de kilomètres et c'est
invendable le produit devient enlevant
dobbs et l'entreprise risque elle aussi
de connaître le chômage technique dans
le pays trente mille personnes
connaissent déjà cette situation il y
aurait plus de 30 % de chômage pour une
population de 2 millions d'habitants
gouvernement souhaiterait que soient
rachetées tout surplus alimentaires pour
les offrir là autour de skopje où 120
mille réfugiés kosovars la france la
communauté européenne ed cercle pays
mais il y a urgence une aide sérieuse ne
viendra pas au mieux à notre économie
sera si l'on pourra parler d'une
banqueroute de notre économie
pour l'heure vasco s'acharne à trouver
de nouveaux marchés
il a baptisé sa société xenos et il
assure que cela veut dire
espérance principales préoccupations des
autorités européennes dont la france
venir en aide population albanaise
encore au kosovo il est difficile de les
localiser car beaucoup ont quitté leur
village la croix rouge tentent d'obtenir
des autorités serbes
la possibilité d'un convoi humanitaire
mais la france souhaite des parachutages
d'être d'urgence ces parachutages sont
techniquement mal aisée car ils doivent
se faire à haute altitude
explication alain du bain avec thierry
breton
l'idée de parachuter de l'aide
humanitaire n'est pas nouvelle elle a
déjà été mises en oeuvre au kurdistan en
1991 et en bosnie en 1994
mais cette fois au kosovo parce que des
combats s'y déroulent encore elle
devrait te monte comme une opération de
guerre
nous connaissons tous à l'évidence les
limites de la possibilité en largage
humanitaire nous les connaissons
mais entre ça et rien le choix français
c'est dire essayons de faire ça largage
à basse altitude entre 125 et 300 mètres
mais là risquent de tirs de missiles
sol-air de la défense serbe pour éviter
les tirs adverses
les parachutages devront être réalisés à
partir de 5 à 6000 mètres soit par
palette de 1200 kg contenant des cartons
de rations soit comme ici sous forme de
petit paquet contenant des rations
individuelles
voici la technique utilisée dès la
sortie de l'avion les cartons éclate et
les rations descendent doucement vers le
sol comme des confettis
reste une incertitude l'altitude ne
permet pas de maîtriser la précision des
parachutages qui pourrait dériver de
plusieurs kilomètres sous l'effet des
vents l'écolier risquerait alors d'être
récupéré par les forces serbes
sur le plan diplomatique maintenant bill
clinton et boris eltsine se sont
entretenus pendant 50 minutes au
téléphone pour la première fois depuis
le 24 mars le président yacine a précisé
au président clinton que son pays n'est
intervenue mais pas militairement et
qu'il n'enverrait plus de navires dans
cette région pour monsieur eltsine
slobodan milosevic ne cédera pas par la
force
des représentants russes doivent
effectuer plusieurs voyages de médiation
messieurs tchernomirdine chargé du
dossier du bus la forme monsieur
médecine doit bientôt se rendre à
belgrade
quant au président clinton il a demandé
6 milliards de dollars supplémentaires
au congrès pour soutenir l'effort
américain aujourd'hui à bruxelles au
siège de l'otan l'habituel comptes
rendus militaires étaient surtout
consacrée à une nouvelle explication
concernant les erreurs dramatiques d'un
bombardement de convois de réfugiés la
semaine dernière compte-rendu patrice en
deuil avec olivier jullien ça c'est ce
que l'on voit une fois installé dans le
cockpit d'entrée l'otan insiste sur les
conditions de travail des pilotes
apparaissent ensuite l'auteur de l'anc
est un pilote américain basé à aviano
premières informations en ce 14 avril 13
avions su r le ciel du kosovo au moment
de la deuxième information l'otan
larguera 9 bombe sur deux convois l'un
au nord l'autre au sud de dako vie tchô
le premier convoi au nord trois
véhicules
ils vont de maison en maison et les
maisons brûlent la l'otan certifié avoir
touché des véhicules militaires mais
peine à expliquer que des cadavres de
civils étaient retrouvées sur place
une piste cependant une deuxième bombe
sera largué sur ce complexe militaire
située à proximité
occasionnant on va le voir deux
explosions selon l'otan il y avait un
dépôt d'essence de là peut-être viennent
les dommages collatéraux
le deuxième convoi maintenant un même
espace entre les véhicules tous de la
même taille tous de la même couleur
cela éveille l'attention des pilotes là
l'otan reconnaît qu'elle a pu atteindre
des civils mais sous entend qu'ils
servaient de boucliers humains autre
sous-entendu la presse n'est arrivé sur
les lieux que le lendemain
cela laisse le temps d'enlever les
véhicules militaires avant de clore
l'exposé le porte parole de l'otan
propose d'écouter une bande diffusé
aujourd'hui par la radio serbe dialogue
entre deux pilotes on dirait détracteurs
je demande instructions vous voyez des
chars non je vois détracteurs c'est quoi
ce qu'on voit des civils
détruisez la cible il est ensuite
question d'un pilote qui s'éjecte c'est
un montage grossier commentera le gradé
américain avant de regagner aviano il ya
deux manières de combattre la propagande
dit on à bruxelles la première c'est de
l'exposé la seconde assez d'offrir une
alternative
aujourd'hui on nous a exposé la bande
serbe et à défaut de nous exposer la
bande de l'otan nous avons eu droit à ce
commentaire la bande serbe
c'est un faible scénario pour un film à
petit budget 26e nuit de bombardement
mais beaucoup de raids ont été annulés à
cause du mauvais temps les avions de
l'otan ont rapporté des clichés
photographiques qui pourrait confirmer
l'existence de charniers de fosses
communes
évidemment contestée par les serbes
commentaires françois cau mais nous
sommes dans le village 10 bis à une
quarantaine de kilomètres à l'ouest de
pristina au kosovo
si l'on en croit ce reportage de la
télévision serbe on compte 70 habitants
et sbisa et une douzaine de maisons où
sont-ils mystère en tout cas on ne les
voit pas sur ces images le nom de ce
village dont on n'aurait sans doute
jamais parlé est entré brutalement dans
l'actualité samedi dernier à bruxelles
au cours d'un briefing de l'otan sur les
massacres au kosovo perpétrés par les
serbes
deux photos aériennes juxtaposés et
prisa et sbisa sont présentés à la
presse
la première montre un terrain vierge sur
la seconde la terre a été retournée on
distingue d alignement de tombes dit
l'otan retour à esbly ça ou la
télévision sert bien sûr ne trouve pas
trace de ce charnier
ces kosovars qui
eux sont encore là ne sont évidemment au
courant de rien tout ça c'est des
mensonges il n'y a aucune tomber
personne a été tuée dans les camps de
réfugiés pourtant les témoignages
viennent renforcer les indices de l'otan
qui disposerait de photographies de 43
sites pouvant être des charniers mais
pour l'alliance
l'heure n'est pas au changement de
stratégie et l'entamé dès la nuit
dernière sa 27ème journée de frappes un
bâtiment du gouvernement de voïvodine en
plein centre de novi sad a été touché
par ce missile une frappe symbolique
plus qu'efficace ce bâtiment ayant été
évacués depuis longtemps alors que
l'otan exclut toujours une opération
terrestre au kosovo et annonce qu'elle
est prête à deux ou trois mois de
bombardements c'est blindé
lance-roquettes multiples américains ont
quitté ce matin l'aéroport de tirana
pour se déployer dans le nord de
l'albanie
officiellement pour protéger les apaches
santis a attendu près de la frontière du
kosovo
cet après midi d'autres renforts
américains sont arrivés à tirana
officiellement encore selon l'otan cette
unité de combat sera chargée de la garde
et du soutien logistique du groupement
des hélicoptères anti char qui
interviendra contre les unités serbes au
kosovo depuis le territoire albanais en
france les premiers réfugiés du kosovo
ce sont actuellement dans des centres
d'accueil spécialement préparée en
région lyonnaise avant d'être dirigés
selon leur gré soit vers des parents
déjà résident en france soit vers
certaines familles d'accueil
reportage à lyon dans l'un des centres
d'accueil provisoires avec virginie
pichet et thierry monnier elle est
arrivée dans le dernier avion de la nuit
plus encore que ses parents la petite a
remis ça de moi a du mal à se remettre
du voyage la longue fuite de sa famille
a laissé des traces
ce que mes vêtements c'est à cause des
conditions d'hygiène dans les camps sont
n'était pas possible de se laver
correctement
alors maintenant la petite à une
infection dans ce foyer d'accueil
ils sont 48 la plupart habitent et
pristina où ses environs leur première
journée en france
ils la vivent comme un moment
d'apaisement après des semaines
d'errance une courte trêve dans leur
nouvelle vie d'exilé ils sont arrivés le
coeur brisé leurs vies meurtri
complètement détruit claude ils ont tout
laissé derrière eux un de leurs rêves
sont membres de leurs familles comme aux
parents ce mes frères nazis et sa femme
sont les plus âgés de la nouvelle petite
communauté comme les autres ils se
sentent ici en sécurité leur coeur
déborde de gratitude mais comme les
autres il ne pense déjà qu'à une chose
le jour où ils pourront rentrer chez eux
retourner au kosovo ce n'est pas
seulement un rêve nous pensons que nous
sommes ici pour un temps réduit nous
espérons que la situation va s'arranger
et que nous allons pouvoir retourner
chez nous enterrer les morts que les
serbes eurent laissé derrière eux et
surtout retrouver ceux qui auront
survécu
les plus jeunes eux gardent cette force
de l'enfance la capacité à vivre
constamment au présent pour le moment il
faut apprivoiser son nouveau terrain de
jeu sa nouvelle maison et surtout
découvrir un autre horizon que la guerre
est ce soir pour la maman d'un monde à
l'autre viendra sur l'action humanitaire
en faveur notamment des réfugiés du
kosovo qui sont arrivés en france ou qui
sont dans d'autres pays d'accueil
journée symbolique pour la démocratie
allemande puisque les 669 députés du
bundestag kit est aujourd'hui bonne pour
berlin et un nouveau siège transparent
soixante-six ans après les
parlementaires allemands reviendront
ainsi régulièrement à compter du 6
septembre prochain débattent à berlin
correspondance d'olivier werner
adieu bonne bonjour berlin 6 169 députés
une assemblée au grand complet pour une
remise des clés symboliques historique
irréversible un grand moment pour le
président du groupe destin ou plutôt
pour le président du reich chaque qui
retrouve quasiment à l'identique le
décor dans lequel on évolue et ses
prédécesseurs c'est d'abord cette
coupole qui rappelle l'histoire
l'incendié du reichstag en février 33 ce
fut le bon prétexte pour les nazis ce
toit qui s'écroule reste l'image de
l'anéantissement de la démocratie en
allemagne en 1945 la ville est détruite
à 90%
un soldat de l'armée rouge plantera son
propre drapeau sur les ruines du
reichstadt les cicatrices de la guerre
ont en partie été effacés reste les
graffitis des soldats russes victorieux
mais tout le monde ne souhaite pas
associer leurs attaques au reich à l'
empire allemand qui retrouve sa fonction
ce n'est pas sain bol ce troisième reich
n'a pas symbole dictature c'est symbole
de la démocratie en allemagne pour
preuve cette toile de maître
accroché au mur de la cafétaria
l'artiste au passé trouble est
originaire d'allemagne de liste on
venait et pique-niqué devant cette
bâtisse monumentale qui ne servait plus
à rien dans les années 60 après la chute
du mur la réunification allemande a été
célébrée face aux attaques cristaux l'a
emballé comme pour lui donner une
nouvelle virginité
les berlinois ont une affection
particulière pour leurs parlements bâti
en 1894 qui prend le nom de domaine
plénier du bâtiment du reich tac un nom
à rallonge pour atténuer la force
d'humour istat lempire qui hante encore
ces lieux d'une phrase le chancelier en
exercice a rappelé que ce déménagement
de bonn à berlin était un retour dans
l'histoire allemande sur les lieux de
deux dictatures qui ont apporté des
grandes souffrances en allemagne et en
europe
cette coupole qui étaient partis en
fumée en 1933 un mois après l'arrivée de
hitler au pouvoir est aujourd'hui
traversé par une colonne de verre qui
symbolise à elle toute seule la
transparence et la démocratie c'est une
sorte de mémorial pour ne pas oublier l'
incendie du reich dike qui avait amené
au pouvoir en allemagne
la dictature lns l'échec du référendum
en italie s'agissait de modifier le
système de scrutin proportionnel ceux
qui ont voté sont très largement compte
mais le quorum nécessaire ne pas été
atteint il y avait trop
d'abstentionnistes en turquie à l'issue
des élections législatives le parti de
la gauche démocratique du premier
ministre monsieur boulin ecevit est
sorti vainqueur
mais la surprise outre donc le succès
monsieur très vite est venue du parti
d'extrême droite
l'arrivée lui en deuxième position avec
plus de 18% des suffrages
le congo et l'ouganda ont signé un
accord de cessez-le-feu en libye une
force de paix africaine devrait être
déployé dans la république démocratique
du congo du président kabila en
politique intérieure française
l'attention se portera cette semaine sur
la droite les contacts ou non entre udf
et rpr hier françois bayrou posé ses
conditions pour une liste unique aux
élections européennes certains élus rpr
parle de surenchère et selon un sondage
csa pour politique-opinion la liste rpr
démocratie libérale perdrait 6 points
après la démission de monsieur seguin ce
soir 7 à chambéry que se trouve le
président par intérim du rpr nicolas
sarkozy celui-ci n'estime pas
insurmontable la possibilité d'une liste
d'union rpr udf
reportage laurent hakim et vincent
bouchard thing
la ville de chambéry était paraît-il
prévue de longue date mais elle prenait
ce soir une tournure un peu particulière
nicolas sarkozy président du rpr par
intérim reçu par celui qui pourrait
symboliser l'union de l'opposition aux
européennes michel barnier président du
conseil général de savoie dont le nom
avait été suggérée il y a quelques mois
par françois bayrou pour conduire une
liste commune avant le choix du rpr
d'introniser finalement philippe séguin
aujourd'hui que tout est à refaire
le nom de l'ancien ministre a de nouveau
évoqué mais françois bayrou a depuis
posé d'autres conditions à l'union je
n'ai rien trouvé
ou presque dans les déclarations de
françois bayrou je dirais plus dans le
fond que dans la forme qu'ils le soient
insurmontables
une confiance assortie d'une petite mise
en garde aux velléités d'indépendance du
président du siècle d'or s'il a du
plaisir j'en suis sincèrement heureux
pour lui
je lui demande simplement que ce plaisir
personnel ne se fasse pas au détriment
du souhait collectif ce soir à chambéry
nicolas sarkozy tient son premier
meeting depuis sa reprise en main du rpr
en amorce d'une semaine qu'ils
qualifieront déterminante pour l'unité
du gaullisme et pour jacques toubon le
rpr a une double légitimité celle des
militants et celle de jacques chirac est
il fonctionne comme ça depuis dix ans
une partie gaulliste continue de
s'inspirer des principes énoncés par le
général de gaulle mais il rassemble des
hommes fort divers et les dernières
décennies qui se sont accompagnées
d'alternance politique au pouvoir ont
fortement secoué l'appareil du rpr
rappelle explications avec jean baptiste
fred-lille rassemblement pour la
république lorsque jacques chirac fonde
le rpr la référence reste de gaulle et
le goal is une exception française
la croyance dans l'état le refus dans le
discours au moins du clivage droite
gauche
le collège possède une certaine idée de
la politique fondée sur la fidélité à
ses convictions et sur la capacité à
prendre des risques pour les défendre
le rps veut l'héritier de ce corps
d'idées il devient pourtant d'abord une
machine
vis de jacques chirac mouvement
gaulliste parti de droite classique
c'est l'enjeu des crises du rpr depuis
20 ans et c'est crise se traduisent par
des affrontements de personnalités 1990
charles pasqua et philippe séguin mène
la charge contre jacques chirac
parce qu'ils nous font donc nous ouvrait
nous transformait nous lever large et
que nous voulons un nouveau
rassemblement en fait déjà pasqua et
sega s'oppose à une ligne plus libérale
prônée par edouard balladur 92 l'europe
et la bataille de maastricht là encore
deux options
pasqua et ses gains revendique
l'héritage gaulliste par le deux nations
jacques chirac sans enthousiasme appelle
à voter oui à partir de 93 avec edouard
balladur à matignon
la ligne est simple un conservatisme
éclairé alliée aux centristes
les critiques parfois sont virulentes
aux réalités et je pèse mes mots
croyez le bien nous vivons depuis trop
longtemps un véritable munich social
pour l'élection présidentielle deux
candidats issus du rpr s'affrontent
edouard balladur compte sur un pôle
centriste libéral jacques chirac de son
côté fait campagne sur la fracture
sociale et le pacte républicain
pourtant élu président la république il
choisi alain juppé l'orthodoxie
budgétaire européenne
après la dissolution et la défaite de la
droite en 97 philippe séguin parle de
démocratiser de redonner leur identité
aux néo gaulliste mais le rpr reste le
parti de jacques chirac
les européennes vont faire éclater ses
contradictions
premier signe charles pasqua fait
dissidents moi j'ai une démarche qui est
une démarche typiquement gaulliste qui
est une des manches de rassemblement
depuis vendredi après la démission de
philippe séguin albert fert a tourné la
page semble-t-il plus de référence au
gaullisme c'est nicolas sarkozy libéral
affiché et défenseur d'un parti de
droite classique qui a pris les rênes
devant le tribunal correctionnel de
paris le substitut du procureur a requis
un an d'emprisonnement avec sursis et
deux ans de privation de droits civiques
contre monsieur michel giraud l'ancien
président du conseil régional d'île de
france accusé de prise illégale
d'intérêts ses avocats ont plaidé la
relaxe
le jugement a été mis en délibéré pour
le 31 mai
réunion aujourd'hui à l'hôtel matignon
autour du premier ministre d'un conseil
de sécurité intérieure c'est un rendez
vous régulier avec les mises de
l'intérieur et de la justice et les
différentes directions chargées de la
sécurité du maintien de l'ordre mais
cette fois
l'ordre du jour comportait de l'idée de
redéployer les personnels commentaires
pascal douce et non dans l'esprit de
chacun les crs et les gendarmes mobiles
sont ces hommes casqués qui assure le
maintien de l'ordre dans les
manifestations
ils le font partout en france quel que
soit leur affectation d'origine ce que
l'on sait moins c'est que cette tâche
n'occupe qu'une partie de leur temps ils
font aussi des patrouilles des gardes
statiques dans les ministères ou encore
des escortes de voyages officiels
on pourrait donc réaffecter quelques
compagnies d escadron sans mettre en
péril l'activité de maintien de l'ordre
d'où l'idée de sédentariser certaines
unités dans les zones sensibles
cela soulagerait les agents locaux qui
pourrait alors se consacrer à la police
de proximité cheval de bataille de jean
pierre chevènement
on a souvent dit que en france
la police était trop souvent une police
d'ordre et d'intervention réagissent en
quelque sorte à l'événement et pas assez
une police de proximité apte à prévenir
et en tout cas à circonscrire les
violences ou des faits de délinquance
quand ils se produisent syndicats et
ministère sont à peu près d'accord sur
ces changements
seul ombre au tableau en ce qui concerne
les crs l'argent il touche une indemnité
de déplacement de 160 de francs par jour
devenu partie intégrante de leur salaire
ils ne veulent pas la perdre
le gouvernement leur a promis
aujourd'hui une compensation la chambre
d'accusation de la cour d'appel de paris
a décidé de remettre en liberté l'une
des personnes détenues dans la sphère du
meurtre des finances et de fontainebleau
c'est la deuxième remise en liberté dans
ce dossier une seule personne encore
incarcéré il s'agit du mineur détenu
donc depuis le 13 février
le premier ministre a écrit et envoyé
une lettre dite de cadrage ces
différents ministres cette lettre fixe
le plafond des dépenses de l'état alors
le moins que l'on puisse dire gérard
leclerc c'est que cette lettre elle est
marquée du sceau de la rigueur du côté
les chiffres sont clairs les dépenses
publiques qui ont progressé de 1% en
volume cette année est bien le seront
stabilisés l'an prochain il ya deux
raisons d'une part avec le
ralentissement des économies mondiales
le fameux trou d'air suite à l'acte rive
asiatique et russe et bien les rentrées
fiscales sont moins en moins d'argent
moins de dépenses et puis d'autre part
la france doit respecter la discipline
budgétaire liée à l'euro elle s'est
engagée à réduire le déficit des
administrations publiques à 1% 1% du pib
comme en 2002 or comme vous allez le
voir sur le graphique
on était encore à 5% en 1995 et pour
être dans la ligne de l'objectif il ne
faudra pas dépasser 2% l'an prochain
donc on serre les dépenses alors c'est
un vrai changement avec la politique
traditionnelle de la gauche politique
dite keynésienne d'augmentation des
dépenses publiques pour soutenir la
croissance
un changement qui selon le gouvernement
serait possible grâce à une politique
monétaire moins réactif c'est à dire en
clair grâce à la baisse des taux
d'intérêt notons toutefois deux
correctifs à cette rigueur pour la
première fois la charge de la dette de
l'état va diminuer et ça laissera un peu
de mou autour de 0,3 pour cent
d'augmentation pour les dépenses
prioritaires que sont l'emploi la
sécurité ou la justice et puis dans ses
engagements européens la france a prévu
sur trois ans une progression de 1% des
dépenses que le gouvernement conserve
donc précieusement pour 2001 ou 2002
d'huile de l'année l'élection
présidentielle avant cette photo fait un
bond à la faisant un petit peu de
démagogie est ce qu'il y a de l'espoir
pour une baisse d'1 et bien voilà
maintenant voir une courbe courbe des
prélèvements obligatoires vous auriez
vous voyez qu'ils n'ont pas cessé
d'augmenter jusqu'en 1997 pour se
stabiliser ensuite alors se met alors
que le gouvernement avait promis de les
baisser
une fera le point cet été si la
croissance escomptée l'an prochain
approche les 3 % et bien des espoirs de
diminution
permis sur la tva notamment si on est
plus près de 2 9%
eh bien il faudra encore en faire son
deuil mon cher claude mercier deuxième
semaine de grève pour le personnel
chargé du recensement par l'insee ils
protestent contre une surcharge de
travail non rémunéré les grévistes même
temps mouvement dans une cinquantaine de
villes cet après midi la direction de
l'insee a proposé un complément de
rémunération
les internes des hôpitaux et les jeunes
médecins généralistes commence une grève
à partir de ce soir une grève des gardes
de nuit des jours fériés l'accueil des
malades est cependant assuré à pau et à
lacq dans les pyrénées atlantiques les
mouvements de protestation du personnel
du groupe elf continue les salariés
protestent toujours contre un plan de
suppression de 1300 emplois arguant de
la bonne santé économique du groupe
pétrolier elf
attention à la pollution de l'air s'est
pas seulement un slogan écologique c'est
une réalité confirmée par une étude de
l'institut de veille sanitaire
neuf agglomérations françaises ont été
testées pendant cinq ans et la pollution
de l'air provoque bien un excès de
mortalité explications hélène bernier
avec jean louis ousset l'institut de
veille sanitaire
c'est ici sous la surveillance de
médecins et d'experts que le diagnostic
a été rendu la pollution de l'air
augmente la mortalité
on s'en doutait mais une étude réalisée
dans neuf grandes villes françaises en
apporter la preuve scientifique cette
pollution seraient chaque année
responsable de 265 décès anticipés pour
cette étude les réseaux régionaux ont
croisé deux séries de données mesure de
polluants et nombre de décès c'est le
premier pays à se doter d'un tel système
de surveillance
on peut dire aux citoyens français que
désormais partir de maintenant
en même temps qu'ils ont des
informations sur les niveaux de
pollution dans leur ville
ils auront également des informations
sur les risques pour la santé de ces
niveaux de pollution 85% des français
vivent sans vie si la pollution
atmosphérique concerne tout le monde
elle agit comme un déclencheur chez les
personnes sensibles enfants personnes
âgées et celles souffrant d'insuffisance
respiratoire pour lutter contre l'air
pollué les solutions sont sans surprise
élaborer des plans de déplacements qui
fasse la part moi belle la voiture lancé
un programme de
je dirais de contrôle des émissions de
grandes installations industrielles et
cetera mais toutes ces mesures ont comme
point commun de n'être efficace que sur
le moyen sur le long terme
encore faut-il convaincre les
municipalités de développer les
transports collectifs convaincre aussi
les français car aucune stratégie
politique ne fonctionnera sans une
mobilisation des citoyens qui un jour
devront faire un choix laissé la voiture
ou porter un masque à lille le juge
d'instruction chargé des affaires de
dopage a entendu le cycliste richard
virenque récemment mis en examen selon
l'avocat de richard vient que le coureur
a nié toute complicité dans le dopage du
sport du football les compétitions dans
le district de seine saint denis
pourrait de nouveau être autorisée le
week-end prochain
elle avait été suspendue en raison de
nombreux actes de violence depuis le 6
avril dernier
et puis demain à bologne demi finale
retour de la coupe de l'uefa
bologne marseille à l'aller les
marseillais avaient concédé le match nul
0 à 0 3 mille supporters marseillais
vont faire le déplacement en italie mais
l'équipe de bologne part plutôt favorite
reportage florent gautreau et philippe
deslandes
il n'y a guère que le foot qu'il puisse
sortir bologne de sa torpeur printanière
le match contre marseille commence à
occuper les esprits et les pages des
journaux tout bologne veut aller à
moscou où se jouera la finale tant
espérée
la mairie a décidé d'installer un écran
géant sur la grande place parce que
personne ne veut rater ça c'est un
événement pour la ville il n'y avait pas
assez de place au stade au camp
d'entraînement de castel des bolées on
refait le match de la veille un match
gagné par bologne 3-0 contre les voisins
de florence les stars bolognaise sont en
forme mais elle s'enferme et à double
tour pour préserver leur secret
entraînement à huis clos
c'est bien connu l'enfer c'est les
autres et les autres ce sont les
marseillais mazzone l'entraîneur à la
casquette voudrait bien apporter cette
coupe d'europe 1 bologne qui n'a plus
rien gagné depuis son titre de champion
en 64 au même moment à marseille c'est
le dernier entraînement avant le départ
les marseillais se prépare d'autant plus
sereinement qu'ils ont récupéré la
hier place du championnat c'est
important pour aller à bologne avec
beaucoup de tranquillité et d'équipé il
va bien de passer maintenant à bologne a
va bien concentré et on va bien
récupérer les joueurs sont arrivés par
avion spécial
les marseillais sont maintenant en
italie avec l'espoir de disputer la
finale en russie la route pour moscou
passe par bologne une troisième finale
de coupe d'europe en moins de dix ans
voilà l'objectif de l'ol mais bologne
qui a battu lyon 3 0 ici même il ya deux
mois ne craint personne dans son stade
les supporters locaux se demande juste à
quelle sauce les bolognais vont manger
les marseillais nous arrivons à la fin
de ce journal avant de refermer je vous
rappelle deux informations que nous
avons développées tout d'abord l'exode
des réfugiés du kosovo continuent une
colonne d'albanais serait en route vers
le sud venant de christina les camps en
albanie sont saturés les autorités
macédoniennes réclament d'urgence une
aide internationale mais aussi que le
surplus alimentaires macédonien soient
achetés avant l'importation d'autres
productions vient d'apprendre que
monsieur kofi annan se rendrait le 29
avril prochain à moscou
attention à la pollution de l'air
l'institut de veille sanitaire démontre
dans une étude des taux de mortalité
supérieur dans neuf agglomérations
françaises
au lieu dans quelques secondes la météo
vous sera présentée par isabelle
martinet 20h55 le premier des deux
épisodes du téléfilm premier de cordée
adaptation de l'oeuvre de roger
frison-roche à 22h40 d'un monde à
l'autre la mare fera à sin spécial
humanitaires concernant ce qui se passe
actuellement au kosovo à zéro heure
disque le dernier journal sera présentée
par laurence ostolaza à 0.35 le servent
philippe lefait avec thème le fado avec
amalia rodrigues et demain c'est au 50
dans les 4 vérités françoise laborde
recevra monsieur philippe herzog le
député président de l'association
confrontation à 13 heures dont on
ouvrait hashid arabe à demain 20h
bonsoir merci
oh